this very week between christmas
and new year's is a prime time for ski
vacations and the season usually kicks
into high gear in the three months that
follow but this year the pandemic has
left many resorts
struggling the ski town of alta in the
mountains near salt lake city utah has
managed to stay
open during the crisis anna warner
looked at some of the measures they're
taking
to keep skiers safe
even without a pandemic there's no
question devin klein
practices social distancing on the job
it's a fun job
cool place to be he's a snow cat driver
who smooths out the rough spots on ski
slopes
as the sun sets each night but there
aren't as many skiers cutting tracks in
the snow these days
and after hours business isn't what it
used to be
skiing is open but restricted at all 10
of utah's world-class resorts
but operators fear closures that have
already hit california ski lodges and
curtailed ski slope operations there
might influence utah officials to cut
back more than they already have
typically in here we would have seven
rows of tables
along here and this year we have four
the rustler lodge since mainly empty
launch general manager tom pollard
we're sitting here in the bar and that's
usually been open to the public where
people can come in after skiing but
that's all closed out to the outside
guests right now gone too are a third of
russler's employees
nearby in park city with the county's
ski-centered economy
the unemployment rate is above 20
percent
yet the adventurous are pushing back and
doing what it takes for the love of
skiing
i was split boarding today so i guess
sticking to the
back country more to get there he has to
get past
buffy ceruby can you pull up your mask
for me
a five-year chair-lift foreman whose
duties expanded this year to include
coronavirus protection
we're making sure that everyone's
boarding with their masses on
you know we have multiple signs
everywhere so no one has an excuse
we've proven and i think we've seen
nationwide that
being outside on a chairlift in the wind
and outdoors
is about as safe as you can get nathan
rafferty
president of the ski utah association
lived through one season of closures
already
we first met him last spring shortly
after utah's ski season abruptly shut
down
back then he was helping to collect
goggles for doctors and nurses
at a time when eye protections were in
short supply
now he's helping to enforce strict
measures to make sure the u.s
ski industry doesn't suffer a 2 billion
loss like last year they're all
operating here
in utah today under stricter protocols
than even
our state government has mandated but
the slopes here any other year would be
full
tom pollard says many of his regular
customers
just aren't coming there's a little bit
of sadness in your heart when somebody
decided that this is not the season that
they're going to come to alta
copy that thank you yet devon klein
keeps grooming snow
hoping like everyone here that there
will be more skiers coming to carve
turns
so he'll have to do it all over again
for cbs this morning saturday i'm anna
werner
you know i am not a skier but i will say
it is so interesting to
see how interconnected we really all are
because
like other businesses yes people go
there for recreation but you see the
ripple effect
when customers are not there it hurts
the entire community to not have that
but at the same time they're trying to
do the best they can that woman who is
essentially the bouncer
at the lift telling people to put their
masks on um it is interesting to see how
people are trying to innovate and make
do
even giving these challenging times and
what's so interesting and important too
is even outside because i think you you
get this sort of false sense of security
i'm not in an enclosed space
i can just be a little free take in the
breeze right
um but she's saying hey that mask needs
to be up and then social distancing with
those tables taking precautions taking
precautions